Waren es Kriege, Epidemien oder aber lag es
an der Fruchtbarkeit, dass die Neandertaler
vor rund 40.000 Jahren von der Erde verschwanden?!
Die Antwort ist uns die Forschung bis heute
zu schuldig und die Gründe für das Verschwinden
unserer eiszeitlichen Vetter weiterhin ein
riesiges ungelöster Rätsel… Ein französisches
Forschungsteam hat jetzt Modellrechnungen
dazu angestellt und präsentiert jetzt einen
überraschenden Erklärungsansatz.
Warum genau also sind unsere Steinzeit-Cousins
ausgestorben?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Fest steht: Die Neandertaler sind als eigenständige
Menschenart vor rund 40.000 Jahren ausgestorben.
Das einzige, was von ihnen übrig geblieben
ist, ist ein kleiner Prozentsatz von ihnen
im Erbgut des Homo sapiens.
Sie haben sich als mit unseren Vorfahren vermischt.
Doch was genau führte zu dem Verschwinden
unserer Steinzeit-Cousins?!
Dazu gibt es viele verschiedene Theorien.
Wurden sie etwa von unseren Vorfahren ausgerottet?
Oder war eine Massen-Epidemie der Grund für
ihr Verschwinden?
Auch ein Klimawechsel wird manchmal als eine
mögliche Ursache genannt.
Klar ist nur, dass ihr Verschwinden zeitgleich
mit der Ankunft des modernen Menschen - dem
Homo Sapiens - auf dem Kontinent zusammen
fiel.
Fachleute gehen zudem davon aus, dass die
Neandertaler zwar nicht mit einem Schlag ausgestorben
sind; dies jedoch innerhalb einer relativ
kurzen Zeitspanne von etwa 10.000 Jahren oder
weniger passierte.
Laut der Anthropologin Silvana Condemi aus
Frankreich ist dies ein Argument GEGEN das
Aussterben aufgrund eines “Ausrottungskrieges”
zwischen unseren Vorfahren und den Neandertalern.
Ihr Aussterben in mittlerer Geschwindigkeit
spricht zudem auch gegen Epidemien oder einen
Anstieg der Erwachsenen- oder Kindersterblichkeit
als Ursache.
Ein französisches Forschungsteams hat jetzt
einige Erklärungsansätze in Modellrechnungen
genauer durchgespielt.
Dafür haben die Fachleute verschiedene Parameter
mit in ihre Analyse einbezogen.
Unter anderem Daten zur Migration und Fruchtbarkeitsraten
von modernen Jäger- und Sammler-Gruppen,
großen Affen und die Datenlage aus bereits
existierenden Studien zu Neandertalern.
Demnach könnte das Aussterben dieser Gattung
dadurch begründet sein, dass die Fruchtbarkeitsrate
bei den jungen Neandertalerinnen über mehrere
tausend Jahre hinweg leicht zurückgegangen
ist.
Laut Silvana Condemi passt dieser Erklärungsansatz
zu dem relativ kurzen Zeitraum ihres Aussterbens.
Demnach sei der Rückgang der Fruchtbarkeitsrate
zwar “sehr gering, aber er reicht über
einen langen Zeitraum, um den Neandertaler
aussterben zu lassen", so Condemi.
Die Fachleute spekulieren, ob dabei indirekt
auch die Ankunft der Homo Sapiens eine Rolle
gespielt haben könnten.
Denkbar sei es beispielsweise, dass unsere
Vorfahren Konkurrenten bei der Nahrungssuche
gewesen seien.
Die Aufnahme von weniger Kalorien kann nämlich
negative Einflüsse auf Schwangerschaften
haben.
Um diesen neuen Erklärungsansatz zu untermauern,
sind aber weitere fossile Funde unabdingbar.
Von diesen existieren derzeit nur sehr wenige,
was die Forschung in diesem Bereich extrem
erschwert.
Erst Anfang des Jahres hatte ein Paläontologie-Team
einen fossilen Fußabdruck in Gibraltar entdeckt,
der möglicherweise von einem Neandertaler
stammen könnte.
Mehr Clixoom gibt es ab sofort bei Clixoom
nature.
Bitte abonniert den Kanal hier draufklicken
und unterstützt mich dabei Umweltthemen hier
auf YouTube zu mehr verbreiten!
Vielen Dank!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!